mittlerweile gibt es in deutschland laut
dem robert-koch-institut 9000 64
menschen die an corona gestorben sind
und wir wollten wissen wie präsent ist
diese zahl in den köpfen der menschen
und haben in berlin nachgefragt was
denken sie wie viele krone tote hat es
in den letzten wochen oder seit anbeginn
der korona epidemie in deutschland
ich schätze mal so 600 insgesamt sind
9000 64 laut lka okay dann etwas
verschätzt was denken sie warum sie sich
so verschätzt haben weil man vielleicht
so wenig trüber wird das 10.000 weiß ich
nicht ich glaube nicht daran dass so
viel gestorben sind ich glaube ich auch
nicht dass soviel treffen geworden sind
ich glaube einfach dass krone gibt
was schätzen sie denn wie viele corona
tote gab es in den letzten wochen in
deutschland rund 9000 vielleicht haben
wir weiter glück wenn alle ihre masken
tragen nicht denken sie müssen jetzt
sich ein befreiungskampf liefern in der
korona diktatur also das finde ich jetzt
bescheid gesagt also ich glaube dass
deutschland das ziemlich gut gemanagt
hat beziehungsweise auch die regierung
und die bundeskanzlerin auch im
vergleich zu anderen ländern wie
beispielsweise italien spanien oder den
usa
und ja ich denke gemessen an den anderen
ländern hat das deutschland ziemlich gut
gemeint ist schon ziemlich gut
hinbekommen es sind hier viele zwar
unter dem aspekt bewohner gestorben
aber viele davon wären sowieso gestorben
die hatten das alter gehabt ich sage
jetzt mal so es ist nicht schön ja ein
bisserl besorgniserregenden aber ich
denke so wie es gerade im griff haben
wenn sich alle weiter dran halten
kriegen wir das auch schon geregelt